You are listening to
radiolab radio from W.
N y. S. C. E. N. N. P. E. R.
Okay. Let's see. Hello? Hello.
Hi, is this Aero Morris?
I think it's me. Hello. This is
Chad from, uh, from radio lab.
Hi. Thank you for your very,
very nice but somewhat disturbing email,
but disturbed you in the email.
The term truth fascist
[inaudible]
you called Aaron Cloris a truth
fascist. Where were you thinking? I was,
I was trying to, I wrote him an email
to try and get him to come talk to us.
And I don't know why you use that
is a truth fascist that was
meant and lovingly I should say,
ahh, wasn't exactly the right choice of
words. Fundamentalist. Oh, I like it.
The really what I meant is it like,
this is a guy who's always trying,
you get to the bottom of things. I
mean, all these documentaries, uh,
thin blue line. Well,
you've got a guy off death row
actually in a thin blue line.
He made the fog of war,
right? Vernon, Florida. Yeah.
But I contacted him because you know,
I'd recently seen him give this talk
about this one investigation of his.
The for me is like the purest example of
the thing that drives him think it's in
all of his films, this desire, relent,
lis desire to figure things
out, to get to truth,
and it all starts with a photograph.
One of the very, very
first photographs of war,
1855 which war?
This is the Crimean war
that involved Great Britain,
France, Russia, the Ottoman Empire,
and believe it or not, Sardinia,
the fighting took place in what
is now basically the Ukraine.
The Russians were on one side.
Everybody else on the other
half a million people died.
It was incredibly brutal.
And there's this photograph titled
The Valley of the shadow of death.
It's black and white.
It shows a dirt road cutting
through this landscape.
Just one dirt
road
between two hills. There's nobody in
the photograph, no birds, no trees,
no people. There's really nothing living
in the photograph, not even grass,
nothing. What is, you stare at
this road a little more closely.
You realize why nothing is living in
this photograph because this road is
littered with Canon
cannonballs everywhere.
As soon as you notice them
photographs springs to life,
you imagine this fuselage of artillery
fire raining down on this landscape.
This is one really fascinating thing
about photography. It's a time machine.
There's a physical connection between
that photograph and world cause you're
holding this piece of film that was
literally ripped right out of that world.
But the context is God and
more importantly in this case,
you don't even know if that
picture is true. What do you mean?
It turns out that this
photograph is one of a pair.
There is a second photograph exactly
the same as the first photograph,
exact same camera position,
but in this other photograph,
the cannon balls that
were on the road are gone.
Yeah.
So one has cannibals on the road and
one has cannon balls not on the road,
but otherwise they're completely
identical. Yes. He thought that's weird.
Let me look into that.
And there was a passage in any ends
up reading this essay by Susan Sontag.
Where is she talks about these photographs
as though it's just obvious what was
going on. And he was like, ah, that word.
Well I don't like the word obvious.
Susan Sontag was basically arguing
that the guy who took the picture,
Roger Fenton, came to an empty road,
put the cannonballs on the road.
He staged it. Yes, it's
obvious, but that word,
nothing is so obvious that it's obvious.
And so I started investigating
[inaudible]
and so we began a
ludicrous, obsessive dug it,
but kind of sublime pursuit
of this slippery little
fact that actually inspired
this whole hour. So today on radio lab,
we are going to wrestle with a series
of seemingly simple facts. Yup.
Turn out to raise complicated
questions like what is truth?
Is it just a pile of facts? And how
much does the fact of the matter matter?
I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert
Krulwich back to Aero Morris.
I track it down.
Fenton's letters from the Crimea journals,
written records of soldiers who
were in that area given time.
Didn't find much.
I interviewed five historians who
ordered the photograph in one way thing.
Yes, it's obvious he posed the pictures
who, this is a bit of a surprise order.
The photographs in the opposite way.
Really they told them it is actually
very possible that Fenton saw the
cannonballs, took the picture
and then soldiers came along,
took the cannibals off the road to recycle
them so they could fire them back at
the rushes. Exactly. Was that
kind of recycling common practice?
Yes, indeed.
It was actually see at a tie to historian
saying you faked it to saying he
didn't and the fifth Daybreaker
jumped back and forth.
I like the, you call it, tried to call
him the tie that he didn't break the tie.
Well, of course none of none of
these things is subject though.
Vote truth isn't something
that you vote on at this point.
He says he was feeling a very familiar
irritation start. You know what?
Forget historical. What if I
could from the photograph itself,
the very photograph itself determine
which photograph came first from just the
photo. So I started a
being the photograph,
just sort of superimposing them on
each other and flipping back and forth.
A, B, B, a, B, B, a,
etc. Etc. Nothing in any
things. I know what I can do.
I can start studying the
shadows, which meant, yeah,
let's go to the Crimea. Are you serious?
Yeah.
His reasoning was I can't study the
shadows unless I knew the exact direction
the camera was pointing on that day in
1855 which means I need to find the exact
spot where Fenton stood and I had
terrible trouble finding this place.
Is it marked? No.
All of the guides kept taking me
to the charge of the light brigade.
That's site where Tennyson wrote about
the valley of death. No, no, no. Noon.
Not The valley of death.
The Valley of the shadow.
Finally, a guide named
Olga. She was fabulous.
Helps them locate this spot. It's
completely desolate, undeveloped,
still after 150 years
with some trial and error,
he's able to figure out that Fenton was
facing north when he took those photos
and then he goes off to the
Crimean war museum and asks them,
could I borrow some cannon balls? Oh Man.
I take the cannon ball,
take it out to the valley.
Of the shadow of death and I photograph
it at different times of the day,
hoping that he'd be able to see subtle
differences in the shadows cast by those
cannonballs that could help them order
the photos, but nothing, nothing.
There was endless questions
about cloud cover,
whether you could even measure the
shadows on these photographs. In fact,
he now suspects that the shadows in those
old pictures may not have been shadows
at all,
but just artifacts of how the
prints were made and on and on.
So was the trip useful
at all? Not so much.
How many,
how many days did you spend photographing
and examining the photographs of
cannon balls on the road? I
was there for about a week
and then he went home with
no answer to his question,
only that continuing irritation,
but he was like, no, no,
not done yet. Look, when you investigate
anything, I don't care what it is,
whether it's a Fenton photograph or Ahboo
grave or the mirror of a Dallas police
officer. Yes. Complications,
result thinking causes
complications. I'm sorry,
but it's part of that process that we go
through of trying to figure out what's
out there in the world,
what really happened.
Uh,
this is about truth,
[inaudible]
absolute truth
and the
pursuit of truth properly considered
shouldn't have stopped short of insanity.
Okay.
So yes,
the photographs worried me that I
might not be able to resolve it to my
satisfaction,
but then
he's at a party and he
bumps into a friend of his,
a guy by the name of Dennis
Purcell, who is very,
very good with Photoshop when he
called them up. Hello? Turns out, well,
I'm an optical engineer, so he's not
just good at Photoshop. He actually,
he builds high tech cameras. In any case,
they were talking at this party
and the Fenton picture came up.
Aerial told him he had this problem of
wondering which came first and said,
could you take a look at these?
Dennis takes the pictures home,
puts them in his computer.
Then I immediately started
to compare them right away.
He starts noticing differences
between the two. The light changed.
The weather was different shadows,
but he comes to pretty much the same
conclusion as Arrow that those things
ultimately don't help. So he just
starts flipping between the photos,
flipping the back and forth,
back and forth between the two photographs
on the road, flip off the road,
flip on the road, flip off the road,
flip it's doing this for hours
off the road, flip on the road,
and then he sees it. The
rocks on the left hand side,
this little group of
pebbles up on the left bank.
Every time you flip back and forth, flip,
flip, those little rocks popped out.
They moved just a little
bit and when he zoomed in,
he could see that there were five
of them. Fred, George Oswald,
Lionel and Marmaduke, we named them. Yes,
these five guys shifted
from one photo to the next.
And here's the key in the
picture where the road was empty,
they were a little bit higher on the
hill when the road was full of cannibals.
This little rock shift down maybe
eight inches or nine inches.
And from the direction of that movement,
you can order the photographs.
It's basically like this,
you could say some rocks
fell down the hill.
They went from up on the hill
to down, up goes before down.
And if the up photo is the empty road
and the down photo is the road full of
cannonballs.
Well then the one with the cannon balls
on the road was the second picture.
Imagine the scene. Fenton
comes upon an empty road,
but he sees Canam malls
on the hill. So he and
whoever was helping him would have walked
along the sides of the road and lifted
up cannon balls, move them on
to the road. In that process,
they would have invariably
knocked into rocks
and rocks don't fall up hill. They
only fold down downhill. It's gravity.
So case closed. This is,
this has been resolved. Yeah.
Susan Sontag was right for the
wrong reasons, but she was right.
Fenton staged the photograph.
So in addition to being one of
the first photographs of war,
this is one of the
first photographic lies.
[inaudible].
I guess he just figured it was a
better photo. Yeah, or you could say
fitting was a coward.
Maybe he didn't want to get too
close to the actual fighting,
so he'd put the cannon balls on the road
to make it look a lot more dangerous
than it would have otherwise,
or maybe he was after some
kind of emotional truth.
That's what Dennis Purcell thinks.
It's obvious why he did it.
Here's that word again to make it look
the way it felt to put those cannonballs
on the road is how you
felt when you were there.
Which case he would argue
that the second photo,
the one he posed is more
authentic than the first,
but forget all of that. Who in hell
knows what Fenton was thinking?
I really don't know
what his motivation was,
but isn't that kind of the
question at the end of the day,
do I really care whether he put the
cannon balls on the road or not? Well,
I hope you do. If you do, don't you?
Okay.
I do and I don't really, we didn't.
Why would you go through all this then?
I guess this is what I take from it.
Mm.
In flipping back and forth between
those two photographs, flip,
he says, you see the rocks move, flip.
And when you see the rocks move flip,
you imagine feet kicking those rocks
and when you imagine feet kicking those
rocks flip, you feel
the soldiers walking like really feel it.
You feel them hitting into the rocks.
You feel on some deep sense for me,
the reality of that scene in a way
that I would not have felt otherwise.
It's almost as if you've walked
through a pinhole camera into the past
[inaudible]
that world in which the photograph,
that strange temporal evanescent
world in which we live is gone.
But if you can step
between these photographs,
you're permitted a brief trespass into
something that you thought was lost. Yes.
My father died when I was two years old
and perhaps the deepest one of
the deepest mysteries of my life.
Who was he
air all these photographs around the house
[inaudible] I was very, very
young. I have no memories of him.
There's a mystery
about this man who is central
to my life in so many ways,
but who I don't know
and who I never will know.
[inaudible]
Errol Morris, his latest book
is called a wilderness of error.
This story was taken from
his book believing is seeing.
I also want to thank IRA glass for
helping us to connect with them.
[inaudible]
hello, this is Dennis
Purcell, Xero Morrison.
He is good to credit for
you. Here you go. Here we go.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
National Science Foundation and and the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world,
a of the world or information
aboutSloan@wwwdotflow.org Radiolab is
produced by the U N Y C and distributed by
NPR that finishes the
credits by and this message.
Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab
is supported by Squarespace.
The simplest way to create
a website this new year,
make your next move with Squarespace.
Whether that's starting a business
or launching a passion project,
no matter what your goals are.
Squarespace's award winning templates
can help you present your ideas to the
world.
Beautifully use offer code Radiolab
for 10% off your first purchase of a
Squarespace domain or website,
squarespace.com make your next move.
Make your next website.
This is our lady in Manchester, England.
Radiolab is supported by UC Davis,
a globally ranked university working to
solve the world's most pressing problems
in food, energy, health,
education, and the environment.
UC Davis researchers
collaborate and innovate in
California and around the globe
to find transformational solutions.
It's all part of the university's mission
to promote quality of life for all
living things. Find out
more@twentyfirstcenturydotucdavis.edu
okay,
Tobin. Kathy,
we only have 30 seconds to tell people
everything that our new podcast Nancy is
about. Okay. Shout it out.
Gender parents informing
nonconforming Camp Republicans,
Democrats falling in love growing
up, sex celibacy, pop culture.
But really it's about the queer versions
of those things. Nancy, it's a podcast,
not a person from w NYC studios.
Subscribe wherever you get your podcasts.
Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is Radiolab and today we've
been investigating the truth,
fact of the matter and this
next segment to set it up.
I guess all I really want to say is it
sometimes getting to the fact of the
matter, a fact of the matter,
the way Arrow just did.
That can be tricky. Yeah.
You end up finding things that you didn't
expect that are way more complicated
than you expected. The story
begins with our producer,
Pat Walters started for him when he
was talking with an ex CIA agent.
So maybe you've taken me to,
was this the summer of 1981
okay.
In the summer of 1981 I was
being transferred from one
overseas post to another.
This is a pro bono and
I'm a retired CIA officer.
But in 1981 Merle was still
at the CIA and he was posted
in the sticks out in the boonies somewhere
in Southeast Asia. And, and, and why,
why were you, oh, well
that's, yeah, I had a,
I had a little disagreement with my, uh,
previous chief and I ended
up in a, in this remote,
a jungle backwater, I guess
is the best way to phrase it.
Can you say what country
you in? Um, I'd rather not.
Oh,
in any case, as much as Merle
did not want to be there,
it turned out that this little backwater
was ground zero for what was about to
become one of the strangest
stories of the Cold War,
just to set the scene.
The story happens in Laos,
which is that kind of narrow country
between Vietnam and Thailand.
And the time is a few years after
the Vietnam War, right after the war,
U s army left pulled out all of
our troops. And once we were gone,
the communist basically
took over the region,
the communist being the Vietcong and
their allies and loudest the path at Lao
[inaudible] Chateau g,
it was may of 1975 all of a sudden they'd
be a con that La had infiltrated and
they were all over our village. And
I knew that the American Tetlock,
this is Ang Yang. Robert and I
spoke with him and his niece,
Kalia translated for us
[inaudible] lives in Minneapolis,
but in 1975 he lived in a tiny village
in the mountains of Laos [inaudible].
It's part of a tribe called the man and
ink says as soon as the Americans left
Lao and Vietnamese soldiers
showed up in his village,
there was a hundred of them.
They came in cars and in a way you
could say they were out for a day,
they told because during Vietnam war,
thousands of Mong soldiers had fought on
our side and as soon as we were out of
the picture, that's when
the killing started. Thanks.
As it began with isolated attacks,
John Mondo had the [inaudible] par
villagers started getting killed in random
field [inaudible] like did they just
find one of their neighbors shot dead in
his rice patty one day or a woman would
go fetch water and never come back.
Yellow car show John Name,
which are partial far long. It
was a village and I know
the name of the village.
I know the name of the village chief,
the path that Lao, which again
is the communist army in Laos,
had gotten suspicious that these
villagers may have been hiding guns in the
jungle like plotting to rebel
against the government to one day.
The fact that law went over and
he slaughtered the whole village.
That's when we knew that the laws of
humanity had been, had been terminated
and not long after that in his family,
along with thousands of other mung
fled their villages when to hiding the
jungle. This is where things stood
when Moreau got his assignment and a,
before he left DC and flew over to Asia.
I stopped in our headquarters and while
I was there I was brief by our desk
officer who told him about what
was happening. The communist raids,
the among the fleeing,
but then the desk officer
said something kind of odd.
There had been these reports
from refugees, refugees
like Ang about this yellow,
these yellow droplets
falling from the air.
[inaudible]
PBS went out to the camps and interviewed
some of the refugees. Crab who?
Oh area.
I said this yellow stuff that was falling
out of the sky was coming from planes.
We only saw the powders free from yet.
Some refugees talked about powder,
some talked about the liquid,
a yellow miss sometimes,
but they all said whatever
this was. When it landed,
it mean people violently ill and they all
talked about how after this stuff fell
from the sky, when did powder reach
the ground? It's dark on everything,
but behind these yellow spots,
chip are done now, you know,
yellow drops everywhere
all over the landscape.
Ang remembers. The first time he saw it,
she was hiding in the woods somewhere and
somebody came running to him and said,
you have to come and
see this yellow stuff.
Just fell on a village up on the hill,
ran up the hill and sort of crashed
out of the forest and just stopped
[inaudible]
right there at the edge of the
village, a glued Lucia toe.
I learned let p electronic too.
I saw a dead cow and two dead pigs and
several dead chicken and all the people
who've been exposed that they, they
were all having stomach trouble.
Ink says people were doubled over
covering their stomach, riding in pain,
throwing up some, throwing up blood. Yet
[inaudible] people began to suffer from
everything from diarrhea to headaches,
rashes.
There was a person,
and I have the photo right here am my
keeping her capa ma who had been exposed
and her eyes, her eyes were destroyed,
entire leap and many people ang says,
didn't recover. What I saw was people
dying, they wouldn't get better.
They would die.
Marel says the thought in CIA was that
this might be some kind of chemical
weapon. Right? Did it have a name at
that point? Yellow rain, yellow rain.
By the time Marel got to Southeast Asia,
hundreds of these reports had come in.
Hundreds and several thousand people
had been reported killed by this stuff.
But you know, in those kinds of
situations and in Southeast Asia general,
you know, are tons of rumors,
but you have to be careful of what you
believe and what you don't believe.
And you have to rely on evidence,
which it just didn't have
no until all of a sudden
[inaudible]
they did just a few months after Maura
got there and they started getting these
reports that refugees and
collected samples off of leaves.
Some refugees had shown up with leaves
covered in these yellow spots there.
Here's a closeup. This is Matt Messel son.
He's a Harvard chemists and
chemical weapons expert.
The U S government asks to
help examine these samples.
I went up and visited him in his office
and Cambridge. Here's some old leaves.
These are only leaves rug back.
These are all dried out. No,
the leaves are small, black, brittle,
which only makes the spots stand out
even more because they're this incredible
bright yellow. They're tiny. They're,
they're two or three millimeters across.
And Matt says,
when scientists put these leaves under a
microscope and looked inside the yellow
spots, they saw that the spots had a
very high content of toxin called t two
which is a poison. And while
T2 does grow in nature,
the concentrations that they found in
these spots was way too high to have
occurred naturally,
which demonstrated that this
was, you know, in fact a, a,
a new type of a chemical weapon.
We now have physical evidence.
This is secretary of State
Alexander Haig in the fall of 1981
which has been analyzed and found to
contain abnormally high levels of potent
mycotoxins, poisonous substances.
The United States said today it has
evidence that chemical warfare has been
waged and parts of Southeast Asia,
the US obtained a test
sample of twigs and leaves.
Chemical analysis found high
levels of three toxic chemicals.
The news of this poison, this yellow
rain became an instant political crisis.
Refugees and camps along the Thai border
have been telling for years have a
yellow rain or rain that was followed
in minutes by vomiting, bleeding,
and death.
Because everybody knew the
Lao and Vietnamese armies
were not capable of making
this stuff. No Vietnam could
not even make their own rifles.
They were pretty backward in that sense,
which really left only one likely suspect
circumstantial evidence points to the
Russians. The Soviet Union may be engaging
in biological warfare. The Soviets,
of course denied. They were involved.
Soviets said it was a
slanderous accusation,
but the US government did not
believe them. Soviet Union,
the allies are violating the Geneva
Protocol of 1925 and in the summer of 1982
in a speech,
the UN president Reagan officially
accused the Soviet Union of supplying and
using chemical weapons in Southeast Asia.
There is conclusive evidence the Soviet
government has provided toxins for you,
Shun Laos and Cambodia. Three years later,
Congress passed legislation authorizing
the production of a chemical bomb called
the big guy, a 500 pound bomb,
and it's been to be carried on high
performance aircraft and within two years,
the factory in Penn Bluff, Arkansas,
begin churning out thousands of
bounds designed to carry Saron gas.
Why?
This would be the first time the United
States had manufactured a chemical
weapon in nearly 20 years.
All this in effect
because of the yellow rain
[inaudible]
but before we jump ahead in the,
in November of 1982 there were two
days of press briefings by the State
Department, and this is where
things really start to get weird.
The State Department had gotten
everybody together to explain it.
Some British scientists had looked at
the spots and in addition to the poison,
they found something else.
All the samples had a very high
content of pollen from flowers,
which initially didn't make any
sense like why would pollen be toxic?
But eventually the government officials
came to this kind of terrifying
conclusion that in fact, this was a very,
very clever communist mixture.
Somehow the Russians had found a way to
use pollen as a vector to transmit this
toxin. If it falls right on your skin,
it would intoxicate you poison you.
But if these drops should
fall on a leaf or a rock,
then the wind would read, disperse these
Poland Greens,
which we've just the right diameter to
penetrate to the depths of [inaudible]
the lungs, thereby making
it a more deadly weapon.
[inaudible]
that remembers hearing that and thinking
that just seemed completely bonkers to
me. I knew a lot about chemical weapons.
You'd never heard of anything
like that before? No.
So he sent some of these samples
around to other scientists.
He knew in one afternoon he's sitting
in his lab and he gets a call.
I remember the phone call. This is
the guy who called and Tom Sealy.
I'm a professor in the department of
Neurobiology and behavior at Cornell
University. Matt pick up the
phone. Tom said to him, Hey,
I analyzed the samples you
sent me and then he said,
the State Department
explanation is not parsimonious.
Meaning meaning this yellow stuff is
not a chemical weapon that he paused.
He said it's be,
and then he used a four letter word and
if we can use that word because that all
right. Yeah. You said
it was beaten. What? BC,
what we call fecal spot of honeybee.
You tell
that was their idea. Yeah. They
were like, look, here's the thing.
Every winter bees kind of
hibernate during the winter.
There are no flowers and there
is no Paula, there's no nectar.
There's nothing for the bees to go out
and collect so that they stay inside and
confined to their hives all
winter feeding their babies,
fattening up the new worker
bees for the next season.
It's since they're very fastidious,
they do not defecate in their nests.
They don't poop all winter. Right? So
the becoming immensely constipated.
And then when the first warm days,
they all fly out on mass,
do like a hundred feet off
the ground and defecate
all at the same. It is called the
cleansing flight in anybody who cultures,
bees, noses. And if you get caught
beneath the situation, Tom says,
if feels like light raindrops hitting
your arms, hitting your forehead.
So this was their theory that the
yellow rain was not a chemical weapon.
It was just B droppings. They published
this and the government was like,
seriously,
even a bunch of prestigious scientists
came forward and said that it was an
absurd explanation. Kind of
crazy and embarrassing a,
let's not forget that this rain was
toxic and be honeybees and southeast Asia
don't even hibernate. There is no winter
in Southeast Asia. It's the tropics.
So Southeast Asian bees
never get constipated and
they never do the big poop.
Those Eric, good objections. No, Matt
and Tom Counter by going to Thailand.
12 and I flew out there and they go into
the jungle plants and beehives and one
day they're staring up at a high
and in the flesh they see it happen.
The bees shoot up into the sky
and within a minute or two after that
we started to get rained upon by the beef
ECS. So to tell the government, sorry,
we think it happens here too. Wait,
there's only half of it. I mean,
what about the toxic part? The whole
idea that these bees are pooping poison.
That is a hard one. But when
Matt and Tom were in Thailand,
some labs had started retesting those
original samples because you see the
poison had been detected by one particular
lab in Minnesota at the beginning,
but now that these yellow
spots were such a big deal,
other labs all over the world
began to retest them and
they couldn't find anything. The
British never found the trees.
The Swedes never found a trace. The Way
Matt sees it, the analyses were wrong.
He thinks that lab,
the lab in Minnesota that had been doing
this work inadvertently contaminated
the pollen because this lab did
lots of other work with Mycotoxins,
large quantities of these toxins.
The government obviously wanted to be
sure they did their own retests of the
samples. They didn't find anything.
They sent a team to Southeast Asia to
verify the bees do the poop shower thing
and they do,
and my friend, it's a good friend,
Palm Tet, who was part of that team,
told me that in the bar at the end of
this multi-day excursion, off the record,
one of the gentlemen said, well,
I guess we owed the Soviets and apology
on this one. Which hasn't ever happened.
In fact, yellow rain is still,
that's moral again in the U S Army
Chemical Corps manual is, you know,
one of the possible weapons that
might be used. Oh really? Yeah,
it's still there. It's still there.
I have a, I have a clarifying question
before I interpreted that. So,
so they found toxins initially and then
when they looked again at those samples
that talk, some were no longer there.
That's right. Okay. I've got like,
you know, had the Hathaway [inaudible]
at a certain point in our
conversation with Ang, the Hmong guy,
Robert and I talked to you earlier with
his niece, Kalia translating for him.
We explained that the evidence they'd
been attacked by chemical weapons seemed,
yeah,
I interpret that from my uncle,
a little shaky, heightened and
[inaudible] uh, [inaudible] thanks.
Response was if this was just be feces
explains the kids dying the people and
the animals dying.
That where there is this yellow
thing where there are no bees, um,
whole whole villages die.
We asked Kalia to tell Ang what the
scientists had told us that the Hmong were
definitely dying. The mode
were under real attack.
They were being fired at from
airplanes and by soldiers.
And but more importantly, even if they
weren't killed by those direct attacks,
they were on the run through the jungle.
Mountain nourished and drinking
from contaminated streams.
Diseases like dysentery
in Colorado were rampant.
And the way a lot of people see it is
that they may have miss attributed some of
those mysterious deaths to this cloud of
bee poop that looked like it could have
been a chemical weapon.
Hi John Jake with hydro Noosa.
The Ang says no Caicos are more
on a weekend in the mirror planet,
not a chance. What I've seen,
and there is no inkling in my mind
that those deaths were not caused by
starvation dysentery. It was chemicals
that without were killing my people.
So we wanted to know, and
this was an honest question,
did he see something that would
contradict the scientist story?
Did the source of the rain,
was there always a plane and then rain
plane and then rain or did sometimes the
rain happen without a plane?
[inaudible] Sheila, let's learn
[inaudible] potty now.
We never saw what what they said was
that it was always just being dropped on
them and it will always,
always be in drop where there are heavy
concentrations of Hmong people that
that's what we knew. We don't know
whether there was a plane causing it.
It was just a, you just see
the dust or see the, you know,
you have to understand that the planes
are shooting bullets and bombs everyday
all the time and so, so whether it
was a bombing plane or yellow plane,
it was incredibly hard to distinguish
[inaudible] Tamayo everybody runs
when you hear the plane. So mom,
people don't watch bombs
coming down. You came out,
you sneak your head out and you
watch what happened in the aftermath.
You saw broken trees,
you saw yellow in the,
in the aftermath of what had been bombed
[inaudible] and [inaudible]
on it. I saw with my own eyes,
the bee pollen on the leaves
eating two holes with my own eyes.
I saw Paul and that could kill the grass,
could kill leaves, could kill trees,
but he himself
clear, oh.
Whether it's the B stuff or
whether it's other stuff,
because there was so much
stuff coming down from the sky.
Jean Young and my yard
needs either. Yeah. Them
[inaudible] that she don't pay a
court. Yeah. Which hippo had the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
you know, that, that,
that were chemicals being that being
against the mall in the mountains of Laos,
whether this is the chemicals from the
Balm or yellow rain chemicals were being
used, it feels to him like this is
a semantic debate and it feels like,
um, there's a sad lack
of justice that, that,
that the word of a man who survived
this thing must be pitted against a
professor from Harvard who's read
these accounts. As far as I can tell,
your uncle didn't see the bee pollen fall.
Your uncle didn't see a plane.
All of this is hearsay.
Okay.
It's hard. Yeah. [inaudible]
hot hope. Yeah. [inaudible] [inaudible]
my uncle says, um, for the last 20 years,
he didn't know that anything anybody
was interested in the death of the among
people.
Did he agreed to do this interview
because you were interested in know what
happened to them about what happened
and the world has has been on interested
for the last 20 years. He agreed
because you were interested
that the story would be hurt and that
the moment that's would be brought,
documented and recognized. That's
why he agreed to the interview
that the mobile heart is broken,
that our leaders have been silenced and
what we know has been questioned again
and again. It's not a
surprise to him or to me.
Okay.
I agree to the interview for the same
reason that radio lab was interested in
the Hmong story that they were interested
in, documented the dust that happened.
There was so much that was not told.
Everybody knows that chemical
warfare was being used.
How do you create bombs if
not what chemicals goes?
We can play the semantics game.
We can, but I'm not interested in,
my uncle was not interested.
We have lost too much heart and
too many people in the process.
Okay.
I, I think that, I think
the interview is done.
Okay
now, um, that,
that wasn't the end of the interview.
They kept on talking Robert and bad
explained to Kalia that we know we're
reporters. We're just trying
to figure out what happened.
One thing I do want to make clear,
we informed the gangs in advance that
we wanted to talk about the controversy
surrounding yellow rain. We
were very clear about that.
We did not intend to ambush them,
but this interview troubled us.
We talked about it for months,
arguing back and forth about
what it meant to the story,
what it meant for us personally and we
decided at a certain point to bring that
conversation into the studio.
We're gonna play you that conversation
as we originally podcast it and then
we'll have some things
to say on the other end.
Okay.
That started by, uh, talking about
the moment that you just heard on
tape
that somehow that moment was when
the whole story changed for me.
How exactly like
I think that there was something about
like the way that she was pointing away
from the thing that we had been looking
so hard at and saying,
stop looking at that.
Look over here. Yeah.
Like she like she didn't convince me at
all that this wasn't a chemical weapon,
but she convinced me that
we were missing something.
Yeah.
What I'm hearing her say they're not
having been in this interview is quit
focusing on the clo reign
stuff because when you do that,
you shoving aside the much larger story,
namely that my people were being
killed. Right. So what she's saying,
so you're mad as wrong.
That is absolutely into my mind. That
is not fair to us. How is it not fair?
It's not fair to ask us to not consider
the other stories and the other frames
of this story. The fact that the
most powerful man in the world,
Ronald Reagan used this story to order
the manufacturer of chemical weapons for
the first time in 20 years.
If the United States with the manufacturer
chemical weapons again and then use
them because the Russians supposedly had,
then people would have died. Ugly
deaths in the consequence of that.
And that is not unimportant.
That's hugely important,
but it's not important to her. So should
that not be important to us? But yeah,
I think that, I dunno, I,
I think that until she,
until she said the things that she
said at the end of that interview,
I don't think that I had
fully appreciated the,
the volume of pain that was involved
in that moment for them. Yeah. Yes.
I thought, I thought her
reaction was very balancing,
but her desire was not for balance.
Her desire was to monopolize
the story and that we can, sure.
We can say that though. Oh, if you
listen to the words, that's okay.
No,
I just think that they feel like their
trauma has never been fully acknowledged
and that they've attached it to this
because maybe they felt that they had to,
they've attached it to this idea that
yellow rain was a chemical weapon.
And if yellow rain suddenly isn't a
chemical weapon that doesn't just and
validate the yellow rain,
it negates their whole loss.
And I think she might
be right. But it's a,
and I also think that the scientists
are right, it's not a chemical weapon.
And I also think you're right that
to call it a chemical weapon has big
consequences.
So what do you do when three
truths are right at the same time?
This is where we stop.
So that was our original conversation
and when the podcast went out,
a lot of people were very upset by me
in particular. So I think I want to,
if I could add just a couple
of things here. First of all,
clearly it was wrong to say that Kalia
Yang was trying to monopolize our
conversation because after
all we are the editors.
We choose what to put on the
air. And in this case we chose,
we were looking for evidence that
despite what the sciences thought,
that maybe there was a chemical weapon
here and we wanted to find an eye witness
to see if anybody saw a bomb
open and yellow rain come out.
That's what reporters do. We test
truths and that is why I was persistent.
I had no idea what the gangs were going
to say and when they got angry I was,
I was embarrassed. And when I got angry
in my conversation with Jed and pat,
that was not right. And for that,
I apologize to Kaya and
Mr. Yang in particular,
I have to ask questions and search
for truth. But in this case,
given how much Mr. Yang
had already suffered,
I should've done it with
more respect and more gently
[inaudible].
Hi, this is Eleanor Womack
from Brooklyn, New York.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hi, I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab
is supported by Squarespace.
The simplest way to create
a website this new year,
make your next move with Squarespace,
whether that's starting a business
or launching a passion project,
no matter what your goals are.
Squarespace's award winning templates
can help you present your ideas to the
world.
Beautifully use offer code Radiolab
for 10% off your first purchase of a
Squarespace domain or website.
squarespace.com make your next move.
Make your next website.
I don't really know where Tim is,
so we're just going to try. Hey,
I'm Jad Abumrad. Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich,
Radiolab and today we're talking
about truth and facts. Yep.
Facts of the matter. So recently
our producer, Pat Walters and I,
we were trying to get in touch with
a guy, Tim Kreider. Hello, Tim. Nope.
Right there. I think if we just shout
very loudly, like up the window,
we wanted to talk to Tim because Tim is
not only is he a wonderful writer and
before that a cartoonist has this essay,
which kind of gets to the heart of a
very different kind of truth that we've
tackled so far, and that is,
can you truly know somebody even after
everything you thought you knew turns out
to be wrong. Hello, Tim? Yes. Oh,
there you are. You sound great too. Oh,
we should say this is
a story not about Tim,
but about his friend who he named Skelly
just to protect his identity. Right.
So let's, let's try,
if it's okay with you,
if we could maybe just talk about Skelly
as if we were just kind
of hanging out at a bar,
even though you're in a tiny
booth on the other company.
I have a little shred of beer in this
tiny room that would be easier. Tell us,
uh, how you met this guy. Um,
he was part of a group of friends I made
when I was working in post-collegiate
job, going door to door
for the environment. Um,
to knock on doors with clipboards
and get people to donate,
like vacuum salesman, not,
not kind of thing. Yeah.
You're dropped off by a van in a suburban
neighborhood and I can still faintly
feel the dread of, of having to
knock on your first door the night,
which was always the worst. But you
know, like, like being in the army,
it was a bonding experience, especially
because they're knocking on the door.
Stuff was just really, you
know, a few hours a day.
Then there's going out
to the bars afterwards,
which became as much a part of the
job for us as, as anything else.
And one of those nights
out drinking with friends,
he got to talking with Skelly. What'd
he look like, by the way? You know, I,
he forbade me ever to draw him.
I used to put my friends in my
cartoons all the time and um,
I did that once to him and he
interdicted me from doing that again.
So you don't want to draw him on the
radio? No. You know, he's about to, okay.
I'm sorry.
He had this great mop of
curly hair glasses that were
literally held together by
duct tape. And the overall effect
was warmth and intelligence.
But from the beginning he says basic
facts about this guy where little hard to
pin down.
It wasn't really clear at first
whether he belonged to our camp,
uh, the hippiest young people or
whether he was someone slightly older.
His first life hadn't worked
out. Um, as it turned out,
he was the ladder and he had been a
practicing lawyer and he had quit being a
lawyer for reasons that
remain unknown to me. I mean,
I'm not sure it was
entirely voluntary quitting,
but Tim says at the time he liked
the guy. Yeah. For one thing,
women seem to like him. They
were charmed by him right away.
All my girlfriends always liked
him. And beyond that, you know,
he and I were two of the
readers in the group.
We each always had a book with
us. So they began to swap books.
And as they got to be good friends,
Skelly even showed him his writing.
I still have it somewhere in
Longhand, even beautiful long hand.
He was clearly, um, a
sort of kindred spirit.
But then some questions
popped up. One day,
Skelly told him that he had written a
novel and that it had been accepted for
publication. Tim was like,
wow, it was excited for him.
You probably thought you got published.
That's amazing. I wanted to do that.
Yeah. So, you know, I kept
bugging him about, well, when's,
when's your book coming out? Skelly would
say, well, you know, in a few months,
and then the few months would
pass. And Scotty would say, well,
they just pushed it back.
It's coming. And you know,
we had a close little group of
friends and like all people on Earth,
we talked about each other
behind each other's backs.
And it may be that someone else sort of
clued me in like, Tim, there's no block.
Mm.
I mean, maybe he wrote a book, but it's
not being published. Initially Tim said,
well, there's probably
some truth to it, you know,
even if the truth was only the kind
of truth that's contained in dreams.
But then there were other stories.
One of his stories was about having been
married briefly in France and having a
daughter over there. And there was a time,
at least one time when he was on vacation
from the environmental canvas and he
supposedly was going to be in France
visiting his daughter who lived with her,
uh, maternal grandparents there.
And our boss saw him walking on Charles
Street in Baltimore during that time.
Obviously he was not in France
and they were never like, uh,
dude, someone saw you in Baltimore
where you really in France? No,
we didn't say that. And
you know, I, I've met, uh,
I mean I've spent,
I've logged a lot of time hanging out in
bars and you do meet pathological liars
in that line of work.
Um, and, and you know,
I'm always duly impressed by their
stories when I first hear them,
until they pile up and they've, they're
always able to one up your story,
you know, they've always met
someone more famous than you.
Something more tragic has
always happened to them.
And then they start to
seem creepy and repellent.
And all I can say is he
didn't feel that way.
He just seemed like a really good guy
who happened to lie more than most.
In any case, after they
left the canvasing job,
they both stayed in Baltimore
and the state clothes,
we frequently ended up crashing
on the same floors together,
closed down the bars together every
night they take road trips together,
blasting classic rock
and he loved LED's up on.
And after a while those stories,
like I've published a novel or
I have a daughter in France,
we didn't hear that stuff anymore. Our,
our theory is that he did not expect that
we would end up being friends for the
next 20 years and he would have to
maintain these stories. And you know,
we liked the guy so much that it would
have been unthinkably mean spirited to
bring this stuff up. So we just sort
of pretended we'd never heard it.
And he says they kept themselves from
asking too many questions like, yeah,
they knew he had a job at the
opera house, you know, fundraising,
but he was always broke, always
hitting them up for money. And he was,
he was,
they wonder why was he always house
sitting and spending the night at the
library? You just never
knew. You did have to,
you did have to triangulate from, from
the few facts available. And you know,
in a way it was a fun,
it was fun to speculate about and fun
to tease him about behind his back.
Of course, for example, Tim
told us about one time he'd,
his friend nick were up at their
cabin near the Chesapeake Bay,
which is about an hour outside Baltimore.
And we had had a lovely
afternoon eating oysters,
drinking beers overlooking the bay.
And we're supposed to drive to a
train station about 20 minutes,
half an hour away to pick Skelly up. Uh,
he's going to take the
train up there and join us.
And so we break away from our pleasant
set up on the water and we drive down to
the train station to pick them up. The
train comes and goes, he's not on it. Uh,
and we're both a little peeved at having
been torn away from our afternoon to
come get him only to be stood
up at the train station.
So my friend checks his cell phone to
see if maybe there's a message and indeed
there is and the message
goes like this. Hey guys,
this is Skelly. Um, I missed
the train. First of all,
there's the background noises of what
is clearly a bar glasses clinking the TV
on unmistakably the mount
royal tavern, a low oil.
We just knew and he says, so, um,
I'm really sorry about this,
but I was in a meeting that ran a
little longer than I expected and
tried to catch it, but I was
like three minutes too late,
but I checked and there's another
train seven 20, it gets in seven 45.
I'll definitely be on that one.
So hopefully you all get this message
and be there to meet me. Ah, okay. Again,
sorry about that. Hope I'll see you soon.
And then there's 30 or 45 seconds of him
fumbling to figure out how to hang up
this borrowed cell phone throughout
which we can hear the sounds of the bar
clearly in the background.
And I listened to this message and I just
smiled and shook my head and handed it
speechless. Lee to my friend. Nick,
do you give any sense of what's,
when you're not being told something,
do you have any feeling for what you're
not being told or you just think it's
just silly detail? No,
you know, I don't, it was,
he was just a very secretive guy.
Whoa.
Um, and we got the sense that, I
mean he told me once, you know,
the less people know about
you, the better off you are.
[inaudible]
I mean,
we weren't supposed to know for a long
time that he lived at home with his
mother. Um, you know,
which is not unheard of,
but an embarrassing thing
when you're a grown man.
And it became really obvious that he did,
cause if you called his house
sometime you got his mother. Um,
and he had a complex
cover story about how, oh,
well if the phone rang
enough times at his house,
it was forwarded to his mother's
to pick up, which, you know,
I had never heard of that.
I didn't know the phone
company offered that service.
So you know,
we knew the deal but we weren't going
to challenge him on it because it's so
clearly it was something he was
embarrassed about and eager to conceal.
[inaudible]
I think probably saw himself and was
worried that others would see him as,
as you know, marginal or
pathetic or losers and you know,
we didn't see him that
way. We love the guy.
It was just one of us. You know,
there are conditions that
come with every friendship.
People are weird and most of the people
who are really worth being friends with
are weird.
And you learn to accept that there are
unspoken rules in certain friendships.
No,
until the day comes when the
rules don't apply anymore.
Fast forward a few years,
Tim has moved to New York.
Skelly still is in Baltimore with
his, well, his mother had died,
but he was living in the same
house. I still saw him pretty often.
He'd take the train up and we get
some beers and some chicken wings.
And one day I got a phone call from a
friend of mine and he sounded very badly
shaken.
Tim's friend said that he'd been worried
about Skelly cause he hadn't heard from
him for a while and then he called work
and it turned out he hadn't been there
and he knew something was wrong.
So he went to his house and um,
you know,
I think he was able to get the door
open enough to see inside and uh,
he called inform and he heard nothing
and he forced his way in and found him
lying on the floor dead.
The coroner ruled that that
death was drug related.
So I went back to
Baltimore right away, um,
because I assumed they were being
a, a memorial service and so on.
And for a couple of days,
nothing happened at all because
he had kept his life so thoroughly
compartmentalized that no one knew
how to get in touch with his family.
Although at the last minute,
the day before his funeral,
we got in touch with his extended family
and they were able to send some people
up just before they
arrived at occurred to Tim.
Well maybe we should go
through his house, you know,
and just clean up and you know,
find out if there's anything
there that we should, you know,
disappear before his family shows up.
And we were talking to the guy who
first found him and he said, yeah,
well here's the thing. He told them, you
guys, you can go back into that house,
but I'm, I'm not going back
in there. He had warned us,
but as soon as we stepped
in, it was still shocking.
[inaudible]
and terrible. What did you
see when you walked in? Um,
there are aspects about that that I
will never tell you or anyone else.
But suffice to say that
as soon as you walked in,
you could tell that someone had
ceased living like a human being.
I mean, there were heaps of things heaps
and he'd stopped throwing things
out. There wasn't electricity,
there wasn't working plumbing,
no plumbing at all. No,
no, I don't think so.
[inaudible]
and words are going to
fail me here. I mean, the,
the simplest way to say it would be
to say it was clearly a place where an
insane person had lived
for someone who is
mentally ill and left. Um,
I dunno if that's what to call it because
most people who are mentally ill don't
know to conceal their mental illness.
He was just a very gentle,
decent, kindhearted guy.
But something horrible had happened. Um,
but on some level he had, he
had understood that. I mean,
it was a secret that he was keeping any,
kept it locked inside that house.
And I think we were all appalled to
realize that something had been so
drastically wrong with him all this time.
And the single most upsetting
aspect of it was imagining how
utterly alone he must've
felt himself to be.
Did you have ever have moments of
feeling guilt like I should have,
I should have gotten into that place.
I shouldn't have no. That I,
I don't think there is
anything that anyone could
have done for him. I mean, he,
uh, he,
he had so clearly determined not to
let people in to that chamber of his,
his life. And,
and the other thing is that he was
so convincing in his dissembling.
I mean, we really didn't think
there was anything seriously wrong.
Yeah.
He was his best and most decent and
sanest self when he was in our company.
But you didn't know so much
about him. And I guess I just in,
in light of that, I
wonder what it means to,
to know someone or what it, who
exactly it was that you think you knew.
Yeah. Well, um, you know,
the only people I knew of whoever
got mad at him for telling,
uh, what they would've called lies
were women. I mean, he was a guy,
so he was not above trying to
impress girls and you know, the,
the things he was trying to impress
them with where his novel is storied
history.
And often when they found out that those
things were not strictly speaking true,
they felt lied to and betrayed and
none of his friends ever felt
that way. And I always felt that
perhaps as patronizing or nasty of me,
but I always felt that what those girls
were really mad about was that they
believed him, they'd fallen for it.
But in a sense you and your
friends fell for something too?
Well, I don't know.
I mean what I would say we fell for was
the thousands of hours we spent in that
guy's company,
which seems to me like a more direct and
reliable form of knowing than hearing
facts either made up or real. I mean,
there was a day when I'm Skelly and I
drove up to my cabin to check on the place
cause there'd been a blizzard, uh,
and there is a grove of bamboo trees
there and the weight of all the snow had
bent them over the driveway so that they
formed a kind of continuous arch and we
parked and we walked down through that
arcade and we would tug on every bamboo
tree and it would shake the snow off and
it would suddenly spoiling up into the
air and fling it's load of
snow 50 feet into the sky.
We did that with every tree walking all
the way down the driveway and it was
[inaudible]
so beautiful and so much fun
that we cracked up like boys.
And I'm the only one
who remembers that now.
That was a moment that only he and
I were there for and he's gone. Um,
he shared that with me
and nobody else ever will.
You're imagining it cause
I've described it to you,
but that's not the same thing.
And if you don't know someone by having
experiences like that and memories like
that with them, then I would submit that
you cannot ever know anybody at all.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
thanks to producer pat Walters
and to Tim Kreider whose book,
which includes this story is
called, we learned nothing.